hello everybody now that 2015 is done
let's talk about what happened for me it
started out chess wise quite poorly I
first thought had a very nice vacation
with my family in the Seychelles I was
feeling fresh before my first tournament
is Tata Steel chess tournament in in the
Netherlands and that's why I really
couldn't understand why I started with
one point out of the first three games
fortunately it turned out that it was
only a poor start after that I reeled of
what is a personal best six wins in a
row and won the tournament despite
Leicester confident play in the last few
rounds that was sort of the story for
the second tournament of the year as
well the Greinke chess masters in
baden-baden I felt good
but I didn't start off so well I lost
the long game to tonight it in
interesting but quite poorly played game
then I beaten and then many things
happened and I won a very exciting but
far too long playoff against nitrogen in
the end up to that declare highlight of
my chest year was the tournament in you
know so by John
the gaseum of memorial i played my best
tournament of the year scored seven
points out of nine yeah everything was
was great I had one of the highest
ratings that I've ever had then I went
off to to New York for play live
challenge got to to meet some some great
great fans there I was in great spirits
before the before the Norway chess
tournament sure you all know how that
played out
first there was a preliminary blitz
tournament in which I didn't do
particularly well I had some fun and
they didn't really care too much and I
and I got five whites in the tournament
then in the first game yeah again I
cannot add too much more it was an
unfortunate incident but one that can be
forgotten easily if the next games go my
way but they didn't it all added up to
pretty bad tournament so after that I
started playing a little bit better and
the stuff points started coming in a bit
although I didn't play very well then
when I had the chance to finish with 50%
and then on a high note then I played a
dreadful little game in the in the last
round and lost to hammer so obviously I
mean that's basically worse tournament
of that I've ever played and yeah after
that came the
I came a period of of no no tournament
for a couple of months I mean that was
feeling was feeling good then I had a
lot of fun and a training session with
Iranian before the Sinquefield Cup which
started very well for for both of us I
mean not the first game that I lost but
after that I had three and half from
five four from six after drawing with
laughs and then just act left in the
last few rounds which wasn't unfortunate
but at least it was kind of a step in
the in the right direction and by means
of huge luck with with the tie breaks I
was still in the running for winning the
Dana Guru Granth chest war then in
Berlin in the world rapid and blitz I
had for a very good day so play and then
one day that just ruined everything
so that's the thing when you're playing
classical tournament you can have a one
bad day you might not even lose that
game and then you have some time to
recover and get set for next one whereas
if you have a bad day if you start
focusing on the wrong things when you're
playing with a rapid then everything
just goes south because there are so
many games and on that second day in the
Blitz I
yeah it started to go wrong I realized
the things were going wrong I realized
that I was not focusing on the on the
right things I was desperately trying to
make myself yeah
getting the right set of mind but I I
just couldn't
but anyway winning one title wasn't bad
but always striving for four more of
course the European Team Championship
wasn't wasn't very good for me
personally it wasn't a huge success for
the Norwegian team either although a
lien made his grand master title and we
were all very very happy about that but
at least for me personally I started
playing a bit better towards the end of
the tournament so there was some
positives to take from from from that
and then in London yeah I just wanted to
to get some some rhythm in my play again
and at the start I wasn't so concerned
about making draws I realized pretty
early on that nobody was going to run
away with this tournament the plasterer
was probably going to be enough to to
win so I thought let's let's try and I
had some decent chances to win I can
convert them then I finally converted in
the seventh round then it changed a bit
before the last round because then I was
suddenly a little bit nervous I realized
that I could actually win this thing I
turned out into some thump something
positive because at the start of the
game I was very focused and I found some
very good solutions in in the
complicated positions but then after
that some point I lost control a little
bit
and I mean it was exciting very very
exciting game both to to watch I hope
and certainly to to play I think it was
a good thing that I didn't didn't see
all these possibilities because then I
would I would have been very worried
what actually happened in the game was
just that at some point I realized that
I'm too too excited I cannot think very
clearly and I should just play quickly
because then he won't have time to think
either it turned out well and then then
it's clear that the tiebreak rules there
weren't when fair should have been
should have been different but I I mean
I would I believe that I would have
beaten anyone in the tiebreak that day
but the way it happened
yeah was quite quite easy for for me
when I got to to to Qatar a very strong
tournament very well organized also a
nice vacation for for my family so I was
trying to prepare well for the games
every day but also to to enjoy a time
with with them and I didn't think too
much about the results
at the start I made the drawing in the
first round
I've been around long enough to know
that that's no disaster and at least the
papers had something to write
both got a crucial victory in the in the
eighth round guess mommy DRF I wasn't
particularly pleased with having to play
a playoff on the last round but I'm
always confident that I came in Windows
well the situation now is that I feel I
feel that I'm in really a good chess
shape
I don't feel yet like I have a huge
surplus of energy but I I think that my
chess form is is good and now looking
forward to the Tata Steel tournament and
I think I will have good chances and it
will be important to keep high spirits
throughout the tournament because it
there is a lot to begin there right at
the end